ernesto johnson turner sports studio
host you can see ernie this weekend
exclusively the final four coverage on
TBS from san antonio and he joins us now
hi Ernie how are you I'm doing I'm doing
doing okay
are you tired good oh no I'm I'm raring
to go minute go to Senate so anyone
Friday all ready to go for the final
format and once you get through those
first two days at the tournament
everything is good but those first few
days are a little a little long that's
for sure but you know I I've talked
about this when you immerse yourself in
the NBA and then you have to you know
like cram for a final exam on college
basketball how much college basketball
were you watching prior to March Madness
you know now that we're eight years heat
it's kind of like you can you can kind
of look at that and say okay I'm gonna
watch it you know there might be a
couple of showcase games early in
november/december that you might want to
watch but really January February you're
kind of keeping a lot a lot sharper eye
on it and then you're getting some stuff
from your research guys who are saying
hey keep an eye on this guy keep an eye
on this team let's see how this team
does with this guy hurt and then so
you're really ramping up its not like
clamming anymore but it's like it's like
you really you really do have to start
focusing in and they kind of let us off
the NBA for you know for that for that
extended period but no it's you know
it's you get you get into a rhythm and
and and know after eight years when you
really need to start really diving in so
so now you know the team's great and
then once those first two days are gone
and you've got a lot of the field gone
then you can really focus so it's good
the importance of loyal in the final
four is what you know it's Gene Hackman
let's when there's four all those little
guys out there you know I think it's I
just and I think it kind of points out
that especially with all the lower seeds
winning that you know there's not a
whole lot of difference between the high
seeds and the
seeds you know feel like looking like
one who can beat Miami it can be
Tennessee it could be Nevada in Kansas
State I mean this is you know this is a
good basketball game and so I think I
think that's kind of what it points out
that it's a that the number doesn't mean
a whole heck of a lot when you get right
down to and you just kind of you know
line up against the guy across from here
let's see who can let's you can play I
mean I think it's been a great run but
from a team that shoots the ball well
and and it doesn't do anything really
spectacularly but man there it's a good
ballclub how's your bracket I've only
missed like four you know you know what
happened
I started out twelve and oh then I
started out twelve and oh that first day
and I was feeling this much this might
be very special and then and then I lost
three out of it for that night including
Arizona then the next day Michigan State
left and then I was like okay but I out
of my final four I have Michigan and
Romanova okay but but that's all I've
got and and Michigan State to win it all
beating Arizona in a thriller than the
final so I don't think that's going to
happen
talking to Ernie Johnson Turner Sports
studios no it's not final four cupboards
on Saturday on TBS from San Antonio
best place to eat in San Antonio when
we're there is where oh I wish I you
know I wish I had this specific name but
I know there's a place on the river
walkway they come up to the table and
make the guacamole right there while you
sit that's probably that's my favorite
place but I again that's not doesn't
help you very much when you when you're
trying to google it and find where it is
place in San Antonio where they make
walk emolia at your table but I think I
think that would probably be it I think
you can't go wrong with that kind of a
of that kind of that kind of a vibe on
the Riverwalk man
you're just a walking Yelp we were set
up now have you how many times how many
times have you been to dinner what is
Shack like when he's eating eating yeah
he's got wonderful manners wonderful
table manners he has he has but he has a
he has a pretty good appetite and well
yeah you know he's he's great no I like
oh not that you get in
Chuckster and and Shaq and I you know I
I can name it no it's probably just a
few times that we've done that but
nothing spectacular nothing out of the
ordinary it's not like you know Shaq is
gonna eat that no one else in the
restaurant can it's not like all the
food is there you know it's just like
going out with anybody else
especially when they pick up the fat of
course of course have you ever gotten
hit by a Shaq accidentally no he's here
for some reason I have not been the
target of one of his of one of his you
know these hide behind the door jump out
and tackle somebody things he really
prefers to go with somebody who who is
really big so he'll so they'll pick up
Charles every now and then and you know
come up behind him and just lift him off
the ground and and place him on a sofa
but it's I know yeah he hasn't done that
to me but you can't help it remember one
needs to say were the guys impossible to
officiate because he's just so big damn
he does I mean he he will just turn
around in the normal course of business
to go to get something he forgot in the
makeup room and nudge you and you and
you find yourself 15 feet away from
where you started he just can't you know
it's he's got this uncontrollable kind
of you know bulk but no he isn't he's
done nothing to me that we do it was it
all spiteful or attempting to injure me
because I wouldn't be here to explain it
to you
boudreaux's is the place famous
guacomole
so that there you go yeah yeah yeah so
they they have guacamole they make it
right at your table and it's right on
the Riverwalk so there you go yeah thank
you so much your favorite place on the
river walk in there yeah one one final
question has to do with Golden State
can this be good NBA that you you have a
little bit of uncertainty with the
Golden State Warriors right now drama is
always good then we know that at TMZ and
I sure I think anytime you know if you
go into a series and and well here's
what I've been saying that the whole
year like I said nobody's gonna beat
this team four times in a series if they
trot out the same guys that they always
trot out but now they're not and so sure
a little intrigue is is good and and and
I and I still think you know I think it
claim indirect that they'll have enough
to beat it you know a seven seed in that
first round all it's gonna be a little
tougher but then you've got it like
you're gonna have to get him back and
and so what it does is is anybody who
says well that's a lot no matter who
they throw out there that's not right
because because Houston's
Houston's legit and and Golden State's
going to need to be healthy to get there
where they would take on Houston in the
Western Conference final which we have
on to you of course you do of course you
do yeah I just wanted to let you know
we've got the West this year you know
comfort soil and you guys new drama on
TNT and you know good guacamole I'll see
you on the Riverwalk and Ernie it'll be
pretty emotional
I'll see you with food road yeah bring
as many guys as your wagon thanks Ernie
that's Ernie Johnson for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]